okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to tonight's planning
committee meeting my name is Peter
Richards and I will be chairing at the
meeting this evening um some
housekeeping if I may to start with so
first of all we're not expecting a fire
alarm so if one does go off run
um no don't run uh follow us uh out to
the car park next to the pub over the
road we will need to check your names
off against register that you came in
with just make sure everyone's out the
building and safe so please make sure
you do that before you uh before you
head off home mobile phones if you could
please turn them off at the very least
of Silence I appreciate sometimes our
emergency so at the very least please
send them silent I would prefer if they
were off
um as long as they don't ruin the the
flow of the meeting I'm perfectly happy
for them to be around
um we have a lot to get through so let
me start by giving some introductions um
to my far right we have Howard Asner as
our committee service is representative
to my immediate right we have Amy
Shipley who is our solicitor and our
planner is in no particular order are
Alison Willis uh Charlotte dicks Marina
iziak and we have Emily as our planning
manager Emily I think you've got a
statement to make
thank you chair my role tonight is to
provide impartial advice to committee
members and to assist members in their
decision taking
thank you very much and just a reminder
for members of the public as well we are
of course being live streamed and
broadcasted and recorded ready for
YouTube so if you want to watch this
again it's a later date feel free to do
that so just bear that in mind if you
would please um we are uh it is a
meeting in public it's not a public
meeting so only the people that
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so at the appropriate time I'll call
you forward to one of the microphones in
front of you the button on the right
will make for the microphone active you
can probably see I've got a red dot here
so you'll see that and you'll be able to
speak as soon as that's on
um you will have an allotted amount of
time which I'll tell you as when you sit
down I will give you a 30 second warning
before your time is up the warning will
be this
and then I'll stop you at the end of
your time good right let's get into the
agenda itself so apologies do we have
any apologies for absence please out yes
chair we have apologies from uh
counselors Crump councilor Parry for
whom Jennings is substituting and
councilor Eden
thank you very much and welcome
councilor Jennings
um disclosures of Interest as well
please members um I'm going to kick us
off if I may so the first item we have
to listen to tonight which is
application reference
2103775 o u t I'm sure members will
recall in June last year we were the
conservative group were provided with a
dispensation
around the contributions made towards
the Party by the applicant
um we have had legal advice from our
monitoring officer who is here tonight
just to make sure that we we cover this
correctly I'm going to read a quick
statement that has been approved by him
um for you now so
um
I'm disclosing on behalf of myself
councilor Kendall councilor Crump
councilor Mills and councilor Jennings
that we all have a peculiary interest in
this agenda item
During the period of 2015 to 2019 the
parent company of the applicant who is
roscon strategic land made a number of
donations to conservative party or
directly to the two local conservative
party branches of which we are all
members the last of those donations were
made nearly four years ago on the 6th of
June 2019. in June 22 the monitoring
officer granted us with a dispensation
determining a planning application from
from roscon that was heard by the
planning committee at its meeting on the
22nd of June of the same year the
dispensation was granted on the basis
that without it the number of members
prohibited from participating in the
meeting on the 22nd of June would be so
great a proportion of the committee as
to impede the transaction of this
business the monitor officer's
dispensation which is published on the
council's website also makes clear that
the dispensation would have effect for a
period of four years from the date of
his decision unless the parent company
or one of its subsidiary companies made
any further donations to the
conservative party
I can confirm that no further donations
have been made to the conservative party
or either of the local conservative
branches since the 6th of June 2019 and
I therefore believe that we are entitled
to determine this application as I say
that has been approved by the monitoring
officer so I am comfortable that I will
be able to sit and I'm going to assume
that the members that I've named all
that are also comfortable to sit
thank you very much councilor Curtis so
thank you very much that all sounds
absolutely terrific fine um should
councilor Harvey unless I missed through
councilor Harvey will also be included
in that dispensation he accounts the
harveying council form were not
appointed to the planning committee at
the date at which the last donation was
made and therefore they were not part of
that original dispensation and again
I've had that confirmed to me by the
monitoring officer
okay do we have any other disclosures
councilor Harvey please
item five on the agenda
there's garages
um I was I am the ward member when that
application was originally considered to
to grant that uh consent I spoke as the
ward member against
that application and therefore I will
withdraw while that item is considered
understood thank you very much anyone
else I have one um so on application uh
so item seven application twenty three
zero zero one two one ful Primrose house
in Smithfield I'm the ward member um and
I have registered to speak so I will be
removing myself from the table and I
will hand over to the uh very capable
hands of counselor Kendall who will
chair the meeting for that item
marvelous let's move to the minutes is
everyone happy with the minutes as they
are set out in our agenda pack
agreed lovely I will sign those later so
we will then move to in fact before we
do that
um
so uh agenda item five which is
application reference 21 zero three nine
three five very that's pettifer's garage
uh garage is limited in ships and on
Star we have no registered speakers so
we are in a position to delegate could I
have a quick show of hands for those and
prepared to delegate that is unanimous
so we will therefore committees
therefore resolved to delegate
application uh 21.03 935 very petrifice
garages Limited in shipston now we can
move to our first substantive item which
is application reference 2103 7750 UT
land at the north of idlicate Road in
Halford and our presenting officer is
Alison Willis Allison over to you
thank you Mr chairman
so uh the application site is located
adjacent to the Eastern edge of the
village of Halford off idlica road the
location is shown by the black dot
this planning application requests
outline permission for the construction
of up to 15 self-build or custom build
dwellings
only detailed approval for Access is
sought at this stage
the application site is some distance
from the conservation area and any
listed buildings and there are no public
rights of way nearby
there is a cul-de-sac of Bungalows to
the northwest
over here
and some existing dwellings on the south
west corner sorry Southeast Corner over
here
there have been a number of new
dwellings built built fairly recently to
the south of the road so this is idlica
Road and there's a large some large new
detached Rollings all along here
the land slopes down towards the river
stower which ish is in the location of
the pink dashed line and there is a
stream that runs from the north to the
south of the site this is this line here
so here is a recent aerial view of the
site showing the application site
outlined in red
Halford
here and open Countryside to the North
and the east
so
this slide
shows an indicative layout
that shows how the plots
could be arranged around a central spine
road with three visitor parking spaces
and five private drives
there's a new access created from
idliquette Road and there will be some
trimming back of the existing hedgerows
to give visibility
the hedgerows would be re replanted
behind the visibility splays
there are a number of poplars at the
front of the site in this area which are
prominent in the street scene
some have been failed recently due to
Decay others have been shown in the ARB
report to have a short life expectancy
and are unfortunately not compatible
with development close by
additional trees are to be planted in
the landscape buffers
here to the north
five meters width here and 10 meters
wide here
um and there's other tree planting
within the site
the stream is to be retained
there is a new play area at the front of
the site which is linked by an existing
footpath along idlica Road
to the Village
the suds the public open space and the
stream and the other incidental open
space will be landscaped with details
agreed at the reserve matters stage
so the the public open space including
the play area will be offered to the
parish council and or Stratford District
Council to manage with a 20-year
commuter sum to cover the manager
management and maintenance the remainder
including the buffers will be maintained
by the management company
the houses on plots one and two here are
set back behind the open space so as not
to conflict visually with far Cottages
here in the street scene
an additional Hedgerow rather than close
board fencing will be introduced along
the open boundary
in the south south east corner here
the perimeter boundary with the close
which is these Bungalows here
would be close boarded to protect
privacy but we would be expecting a
higher quality boundary treatment where
the boundary borders idlicate Road
to the front here
next to number nine to which would
enhance the street scene
so in the report you'll see the usual
spread of conditions but additionally
the permission would include a condition
restricting the use of the site to self
and custom build housing only
so it wouldn't be open market dwellings
this location adjacent but outside the
built up area boundary is justifiable is
there is a just district-wide
underprovision of self and custom build
sites which we are as an authority
required to address
so we have a number of tailor-made
conditions drafted for this type of
proposal
the first Reserve matters application is
to be submitted within two years and to
include all the site infrastructure
so for example this would this would
include the layout of the internal
Access Road foot ways any shared
surfaces visitor car parking facilities
maneuvering areas any external lighting
hard and soft Landscaping details for
all the site infrastructure public Open
Space Landscape buffers perimeter
boundary treatments and all the
incidental open space which isn't
Incorporated within the residential plot
cartilages
there'll be a refuse and recycling
strategy
of the detailed surface water drainage
scheme
and details of the management and
maintenance scheme for the site
infrastructure and public open space
so the subsequent Reserve matters
applications for the individual plots
would be submitted within three years
and begun within two years of the
approval of the last Reserve matters
application
this would minimize local disruption by
not enabling an extended period of
development
so this slide shows the parameters plan
this is this plan and the plot layout
plan
this one that would be approved at the
at this outline stage
it shows the plot boundaries
the separation distances
the build areas
the frontage lines
Garden sizes
which together with the design code
would secure the context for further
Reserve matters applications for the
individual plots
detailed consideration for each dwelling
would occur at Reserve matters stage and
would be in accordance with our normal
development requirements
the detailed stage would include a
statement providing an explanation as to
how the design of the development
responds to the details submitted as
part of the outline application
and how the application responds to the
principles of the design code including
how it responds to the local character
in Halford
the subsequent Reserve matters
applications for each individual
individual plot will also contain
detailed detailed evidence of how and
when the purchaser has had primary input
into the design and layout of the unit
self in custom-built housing can cover a
wide spectrum from projects where
individuals are involved involved in the
building and managing
the construction of their own home from
beginning to end
or projects where individuals commission
their homes making key design and layout
decisions but the home is built ready
for occupation
so this slide it's a few looking south
from the northern edge of the site with
illicit road on the horizon you can just
about see the tops of the houses
this this photo at the bottom is the
ditch that runs north south through the
site down towards the river
these are the neighboring properties on
idlicate road with the site visible
through the Gap here
and on the other side of the the wire
fence here
these are the houses along the
Northwestern boundary
so these three are the Bungalows on the
close
and the house this house here is the one
fronting onto it look at Road that's
just being extended
so that's the end of the presentation Mr
chairman the updates are as shown on the
update sheet
the recommendation is that the
application be granted for the reasons
detailed in the report subject to the
conditions and notes and completion of a
section 106 agreement the detailed
wording and numbering of which is
delegated to officers thank you
Allison thank you very much indeed
members I'm going to assume you've had
an opportunity to read the update sheet
yep marvelous okay let's call our first
Speaker for the evening who is counselor
Nicholas Gale chairman of Halford Parish
Council
good evening councilor Gail
and welcome
now when you're settled and comfortable
you will have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second one before
your time is up as I said you'll hear
the the Bell go when when your 30
seconds is approaching the button on the
right hand side will get you going so
it'll turn your microphone on otherwise
when you're ready the floor's yours
right
it should be remembered that for a very
valid planning reasons a prior
application in respect of this site by
Carla Holmes was refused
the proposed development of 27 homes has
now been superseded by 15 self-built
properties
it was the opinion of the planning
Authority that the original proposed
development was considered excessive
given the special nature of Halford
Village
the fact that what is now proposed I.E
15 self build does not change the
situation very much it is too many
houses on an unsuitable site
for unsuitable new homes are currently
being built on the old Bowling Green off
the first way and some eight homes have
been built or have current planning
permission to build along the illicard
road this would mean a total of 27 New
properties in three years it's literally
far too many
the access to the new development is
Vara Lane not a road it is narrow and
used by a large number of huge tractors
from locals Farms
totally unsuitable for a significant
number of Constructors Vehicles
accessing the new site over a percent or
very long period of build time
The Proposal Falls outside the built-up
area boundary and the cartilage of this
small village
this brought part of the reason that the
original application was declined and
nothing has changed really
the village is a garage and a chaos were
not a shop as such there is no school a
very limited bus service and the village
simply does not warrant a development of
this nature
Halford is currently a compact and very
sociable Village and it has been
demonstrated the new developments of
this nature do not add anything to the
Village infrastructure whatsoever
known sewers problems and flood risks
have been inherent over the years and
the situation will certainly not be
improved by this development
I would ask the panel to seriously
consider this application and deny
permission to develop the site
thank you
well ruin your time thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for Cancer girl please Council Mills
first thank you good evening
um does Halford have a neighborhood plan
no it doesn't it's a very small village
the parish council is only of three
members and we simply do not have the
resources to do it
thank you very much Council seraphin
sorry I was going to ask the same
question
councilor Curtis
it may be the same a similar question
but I Wonder has the parish council
carried out a housing needs survey for
the village no no no
anyone else
nope in that case Council gal thank you
very much for your time contribution
okay let's call our next speaker who is
Liz Nicholson on behalf of the applicant
good evening and welcome
you've been here many times before you
know the drill so three minutes 30
second warning and when you're ready the
floor is yours thank you
we recognize that the council and
potential developers have had to
undertake a lot of learning over the
last two or three years whilst we've
been grappling with the principles of
self and custom-built housing
and we would like to thank your officers
both in your development management and
your policy teams for their hard work in
this regard
roscom's strategic land of the stands
gate have worked hard with your officers
to design a high quality scheme and an
Associated design code that meet all the
relevant policy requirements and address
all the technical points raised by the
consultees
in the planning press just this week
there have been a number of Articles
written about the national position
regarding self and custom-built housing
schemes from these it would seem that
some authorities are continuing to bury
their heads in the sand when it comes to
their legal duty to provide service
plots however it's also apparent that a
good number of councils are now
embracing these types of schemes and
approving proposals for service plots to
meet the demand identified in their self
and custom build registers
we recognize the situation that this
council is currently in when the
legislation for self and custom-built
housing came into effect the core
strategy was at such an advanced stage
it was not possible to take that
legislation into account so the council
has been left without a policy to guide
decision making on this type of housing
the council still has a legal duty to
provide enough plots to meet demand and
that's a duty it's currently failing to
meet and this leaves it exposed to the
risk of applications being approved on
appeal has happened in Welford on even
in January this year
even without a core strategy policy the
council can take control of the
situation that finds itself in by
approving schemes on suitable sites in
appropriate locations as identified in
its revised draft site allocations plan
whilst we're all agreed that this
document only has limited weight at this
time it is nevertheless material
consideration along with the recent
appeal decision in Welford and the
continuing updated evidence of the
substantial shortfall in provision
within the district
this scheme in Horford for 15 service
plots will make a meaningful
contribution to meeting the council's
legal responsibilities to provide
sufficient service plots for this type
of housing need on a site which is
allocated in the revised draft site
allocations plan
there are no technical grounds on which
to refuse the application and in
conclusion we would ask that the
development is supported
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions
please no in that case Miss Nicholson
thank you very much for your time
contribution
okay let's call our last speaker on this
item who is councilor wooly hoggins who
is substituting for councilor O'Donnell
good evening councilor
and when you're sat comfortable and
ready to go you will have five minutes
again I'll give you 30 second warning
before your time is up when you're ready
the floor is yours
good evening the proposal for 15
self-built properties in Halford
particularly on the idliquette road and
on this site is mind-boggling this is
currently open Countryside and well
outside the built up area has been shown
on many pictures that you've already
seen an attempt is being inflicted on
residents because Stratford District
Council has not yet managed to allocate
any other land for South bills this is
grossly unfair
this is a narrow single track Lane that
I know well whose only narrow pavement
allows for one person without a dog to
use it quite simply the scale of the
disruption to Residents and the very
real dangers it will cause must be a
very serious consideration for this
committee as it was previously for the
proposed development of the gala Homes
at no point has a landowner approach to
Paris Council to this to discuss his
desire to apply for planning approval
had they done so although they might
have been discomfort about losing this
green finger of land in the village
there would have been an opportunity to
discuss the need for any proposed
development if approved to be carefully
managed therefore a reputable Builder
skilled in site management might have
been preferable this would have also
provided the opportunity with the
development of this proposed site to
have had some much needed affordable
housing including in the build and some
sill payments which for a development of
this size would have been very
beneficial for a small village like
Halford South bills I understand are
devoid of any civil payments there will
be no benefit to the local community or
residents in the building of this large
number of self-built homes the
disruption of the build will go on for
years as different plot purchases
organize our building and finances to
build on unique and best spoke time
scales with a self-built development of
this scale there will be multiple
large-scale deliveries on a daily basis
for years the road is quite unsuitable
for such a prolonged and complicated
scheme that you have before you Halford
is a lovely Village the residents are
not nimbies they simply want the best
sort of housing available for the needs
of the whole village and housing that is
sustainable in the long term for
generations to come The Village does not
need another 15 enormous executive style
homes as Council Nick Gale pointed out
all the houses that have been built
recently I think it was 20 something
have all been of gargantuan proportions
with gargantuan price tags so there are
50 people who wish so the village does
not need another 15 enormous executive
style homes either self-built or
otherwise the developer and landowner
has not provided any proof that there
are 15 people who wish to build a
self-built property in Halford at the
price it will cost this application is
therefore audacious what the village
need is engagement from the landowner
about preferences from the residents
some of whom would like to see
affordable homes and starter homes so
that we can be a multi-generational
village which is able to welcome those
from all financial backgrounds
to summarize this type of these type of
houses the self-built nature of the
houses on the location combine to make
this application wholly unsuitable this
is not a suitable scheme and it is not a
suitable location thank you
that's what Huggins thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for our substitute War member
nope in that case casual against thank
you very much for time contribution this
evening
okay we will move now to points of
clarification with our officers does
anyone have any points they want to
clarify councilor Jennings first please
the wellsford appeal was mentioned how
relevant is that here
um
obviously each
decision each other each site is
considered on its own merits
um so in the officers making their
recommendation
um they've had regard to
um the the policies and the material
planning considerations relevant to this
site in honesty I wouldn't be able to
um
give you a definitive answer as to what
the the reasons were for the decision on
the Welford to actually have been
refused and why the inspector considered
that it was appropriate to
to allow the appeal so I wouldn't want
to say that it's it is relevant in this
circumstance because obviously the
circumstances that led to that refusal
may be different to the specific
circumstances on this site
um would clear as much as the expression
I believe
councilor Harvey thank you chairman
um can I refer to page 31 of the
officers
reported one of the papers
um
revealing my ignorance I'm concerned
that the aid there's a need for a bioset
offset scheme
um
and I don't know whether it would be
something that would be considered that
outline stage or Reserve matter stage
but my point of concern is I would like
to see if this application were to be
approved that any environmental
environmental offset scheme was
delivered before development started not
afterwards is that possible
[Music]
um so the offsetting scheme can take a
number of forms so the biodiversity
impact assessment has shown that there's
a need for a
um to provide a scheme to the value of
3.48 biodiversity units so the the
section 106 will include Provisions
where
um
the developer can either make a
financial contribution
for the equivalent monetary value
or they can buy
uh
like offsetting at a site that provides
like for example a site where which
plants trees
so they can purchase it that way
or their free
to purchase
so they can do either or a combination
so it's it
so it's
it's a requirement of the section 106
that will be submitted to The District
Council
I'm I'm still left with
the feeling that that doesn't that may
provide an agreement about what is to
happen
and if it's money well that's that's
fine I understand it's either money or
something off-site so it's not physical
um works on the site you know I
understand that if it is to be off-site
my point is that that should be
delivered before development takes place
because I have experience where off-site
uh provision is required to be made as
part of a 106 and it and it doesn't
happen and it ends up five years later
down the track being a matter of
enforcement I would prefer to see a
developer provide the off-site
offset before before work starts because
there's there's no argument about it at
that stage
foreign
I'm going to follow up that question
myself with
um it am I right in thinking the offset
scheme where I think you can buy credits
or tokens or something
um is a national scheme the social
almost National policy that we
uh sort of work with
um and the delivery of the biodiversity
is a County Council
run scheme rather than a district
council run scheme I appreciate that's
one option uh but that's the County
Council scheme is that right yes all
right phone back on please
so the developer can have a choice
when they when when the section 106 is
drafted they will have the choice of
meeting their requirement in any one of
those three ways
thank you Council Mills please
thanks Mr chairman um it's um top of
page 14
um
it says the post site Falls in open
Countryside outside the Divine built up
area boundary and then it goes on to say
I therefore consider the application
does not comply with the policy cs-1516
and as10 can you explain to me a little
bit more about that please
so the
boundary is does it start there so it
runs down this boundary here
so if you can see on that one I don't
know why it's much
so the built-up area boundary is up and
down this boundary here so this site
here is technically outside the built up
area boundary
so it doesn't comply with
yeah okay
thank you okay councilor Adam please
thank you I've got two questions I'll
just go through the first one
um which hopefully be quite simple on
the update sheet you note that the
protected species and refuge strategy
conditions have been Amalgamated could
just clarify how those are still covered
by the remaining conditions please
so in the original when I originally
drafted the report with the original
summary of the conditions I had a
separate protected species condition and
a
a separate Environmental Management plan
condition so it was felt when we were
reviewing the drafted conditions that
they could be Amalgamated still achieve
the same thing
um it just I suppose it's just less
less words I suppose and in terms of the
the bin the waist and recycling strategy
I I think as originally drafted I'd
required a waste waste strategy
um and a separate
bin compliance
condition so those have been Amalgamated
just because of the same topic
well um so the the first second question
which was a different matter was
relationship to the highway Network and
the the comments from County highways
um I suppose in two parts is the
the response we've had from the highways
Authority in relation to just the
highways on site and the and the say the
visibility splays to it or does it
consider access from say the Foss way up
to the site because obviously concern's
been raised about the adequacy of that
road in particular
they would look at the impact of The
Proposal on the highway Network and look
at it from a highway safety point of
view on the network not and as well as
the immediate access points on the site
um so I suppose that the only follow-up
to that then um looking at the because
obviously what one aspect that was noted
in this was the the sap which obviously
draws upon the uh Schlage document which
um a notice has a poor essentially flag
that the relationship to the highway
Network being an issue
would you see that that assessment that
we have made in the schlar document is
at odds with the highways assessment or
does it supersede it how do those two
sort of decisions relate to each other
um I don't think with all due respect
and my colleagues in policy I think when
they put together the the sap document
and the criteria that they that they
don't examine it in the same degree that
we've rigorously examined it through the
course of a planning application
Curtis please
thanks Jay um just a few points if I
could
um first of all uh councilor Wally
hoggins said that no seal payments were
payable on this and there was there
would be no requirement for affordable
housing can you just can confirm those
two points
thank you
so uh
if you
prospective purchases of self and custom
build plots
they can apply to be exempt from cell
so the initial purchaser as long as they
submit a part one still exemption form
prior to commencement development and
then a sill exemption
form or prior to occupation they're
exempt the condition of the exemption is
that they have to live in the house for
three years
so they they could be some exemption on
all these and there is no requirement
for any affordable housing that's
correct not no not not on self-imp
custom build
just a couple of other points if I made
share
um
you mentioned that part of the criteria
for this custom self build is primary
into primary input into design key
design and layout decisions but is there
any definition
of what primary input into design
actually is no I don't think there is a
definition of what primary input is it
is required in the legislation that we
considerate and I think we'll take each
case on its merits and with each Reserve
matters application for each plot we
will be asking for a statement from the
applicant for them to demonstrate that
they have how they've interpreted that
and we will consider it but if there is
no definition it's quite hard to see how
that can be
agreed if you like
um sorry Chad we've just got two other
quick points one
um
what I'd be interested to know what the
what what a biodiversity unit is and how
it's measured and also on page 27
um talk about the public open space
including the play area and that will be
managed with a 20-year commuted sum can
you tell us how the commuted sum would
be calculated thank you so in
Warwickshire we're quite lucky there was
a pilot project
um I think probably about five seven
years ago where there are a number of
councils across the country took part in
a pilot scheme to devise a by a metric
tool
um we are very lucky that we've got one
of the country's experts and the tool
that we developed here in Warwickshire
has stood the test of time where a lot
lots of them have failed uh nationally
so the Warwickshire
biodiversity impact assessment tool
which is what we most commonly have been
using and it compares
the existing habitat types and their
distinctiveness and their quality with
what's proposed so it's a it's like a
tool for us assessing the before and
after scenarios
um but it it uses the kind of national
classification of habitat types
um to compare before and after it looks
at what's being lost and what's being
gained and looks at how considers how
how like each type of habitat has got a
distinctive in score and it also can
considers How likely
that is to be attained and there's all
sorts of Corrections within the kind of
formulas for it
um that is has that metric has is being
replaced by a national metric which is
referred to as defrometric which is
going to be compulsory from November
this year onwards
um
and so so that our Warwickshire one is
going to be phased out I think so that
the the score the the net loss so the
the Warwickshire metric
gives you a score at the end which is
equivalent to a number of units either
gained or lost so we always obviously
try and secure a net gain at the moment
um so on this site there's a net loss of
uh 3.48 which is equivalent to I think
it was about a hundred and
119 000 pounds equivalent roughly not
more than
um and that's a calculation that the
ecologists will input all the
information into the spreadsheet and the
County Council will interpret it and
provide that figure
and my other point was that the how the
commuted sum would be calculated
um so
at the first Reserve matters application
stage we would agree the detailed
specification for the public open space
and we will also agree on management and
maintenance scheme so the
once we've got those two documents we
will then be able to go out and get
quotes uh for
um the mat for like a Year's worth of
management and maintenance of that
particular open space and I think the
intention is would be to get to get
three quotes
and then find the average and then then
multiply that by 20 years
simply
but yes yeah it's all index linked
Council Mills Please Mr Jim um Allison
um it was refused was it seven years ago
for 2820s I know this is
is that the difference when everybody's
being granted because it's a smaller
development or was it other other issues
a picture of it
oh that was it
so that's the Carla scheme that was
refused
um so it's the same plot but it's 28
houses and the
it was for
erection of 28 dwellings and Associated
infrastructure Works including
sustainable drainage works and equipped
play area with access off idlicate road
so a similar spine road but obviously a
lot less a lot more houses
um the the site that I've obviously that
that we're in front of us today is 15
dwellings this was 28.
um so we're only considering this site
today because it's self and custom build
and there's a district-wide deficit of
self and custom build
plots that's that's the difference
really this was just normal open market
housing
okay any other points that need
clarifying
no before we move to the debate I did
see Miss Nicholson's hand go up I do
have the option to call you forward for
a point of fact a disputed point of fact
is that what you were wanting to come
forward for do you want to make your way
forward to the seat in front please
thank you chair I wouldn't normally want
to do this but the first question that
was asked
um was about the Welford appeal and your
officers said it was refused
it wasn't refused your committee
supported that scheme in principle we
ran into difficulties trying to agree
the section 106 the details of how you
secure self and customer build in the
end we felt we had no choice but to go
to non-determination appeal
so that was what happened with the
Welford scheme it was ten dwellings
and I think
what you're being asked to do because
there was another question about the
boundary and the policies CS 15 16 and
10 as10
we all accept this is outside the built
up area boundary
it's therefore in conflict with those
policies the policies
have been determined to have moderate
weight because they don't directly refer
to self-build you have nothing
specifically about self-build so they've
got a little bit less weight because of
that they've got moderate weight rather
than full weight
however your shortfall on self-build is
a material consideration in the welfare
appeal the inspector said that is a
material consideration that outweighs
the policies that have moderate weight
so hopefully I've stuck to the facts and
not tried that you push the boundaries I
think but you I'm I'm happy
okay thank you very much for that
members
um let's move into debate who would like
to kick us off
don't all jump cancer Jennings
okay and obviously this is all about um
a gap in in policy and we we keep on
coming up with this every time we have
self builds and obviously when the
original policies were drawn up
self-bills I guess weren't a thing so
that but obviously since then government
legislation has changed and we're sort
of
filling up filling the Gap with the sap
at the moment
um
we do have a legal obligation to provide
these self builds and uh
we're short on numbers at the moment
we've got the 76 we have two we have to
allow
um I'm not going to propose anything at
this stage but I'm
um I guess I'm leaning towards the
officer's recommendations
um and I don't see a material planning
reason to go against them at this stage
I'm
waiting for everyone else to have this
okay Council Mills next please
yeah thanks Jim I I actually you can
probably guess by my tone
um
a little bit that's all uncomfortable
with this one um Mr chairman
um
it is outside the built up area boundary
and we have the same thing in our
village we we don't want this you know
and
and have you said before you know
policies are policies and um okay uh Liz
was saying it holds media medium weight
because of its self build
but they are still there
um
I'm just uncomfortable about it at the
moment Mr chairman I'll wait to see what
everybody else has to say thank you okay
thank you very much Council Kendall
please
yeah
I think I'm in exactly the same position
as Council Jennings councilman Mills I'm
I am struggling to see a reason to go
against but I am very very uncomfortable
with the fact this is outside of the
built Perry boundary and
and that's what I'm going to say for a
second I'll come back later if that's
okay
okay Council Curtis please
thanks Jeff
um I'm just looking at page 14 of the
report the custom self-building custom
house building Act 2015.
and it's just worth re looking at the
wording the purpose of this act is to
help diversify the housing market
increase consumer choice and tackle the
housing crisis now we've heard from the
parish council that this isn't the type
of housing that's required there it's
not so it doesn't seem that this
self-built is helping diversify the
housing market nor increasing consumer
choice and it's not essentially tackling
the housing problem that we have in the
district and regarding
the the comments by layers and others
about the the weight of policies I think
in the end it is up to this Committee
just to as we all know to decide what
weight we give to various policies when
coming to our decision thank you chair
thank you very much councilor councilor
Andrew seraphin next please
thank you yes I'm extremely
uncomfortable with this uh there seems
to be a lack of consultation with
Halford Parish Council
um
these sort of developments actually
destroy a village because if there's any
young people in the village want to
retain
a new house built in the village they
couldn't afford this type of house
anyway and I'm always skeptical of
self-bill
custom built because
I've been in the building trade on when
I self-builders you build it yourself
and you live there
for a long time it's nothing about
making a big profit but I feel that
these houses are too big and we will
actually spoil the village
and I am very uncomfortable with it
thank you
Council Harvey next please
um
I share the unease
this is building the open Countryside
and normally if it wasn't self-built
unlike that we would approve
but this is a matter of legislation
being imposed as well as a decision from
the inspectorate which is Bear's
relevance
the agent when she made her presentation
made the statement that the application
complies with policy
and I haven't heard from the case
officer any information to counter that
and while I hear
words that were said about the the lack
of affordable housing
while I hear about the state of the the
road the lane and whether it can cope
with the volume of traffic and so on
nevertheless we have statutory
authorities who've said the road's okay
there is no requirement within the
legislation that that affordable housing
forms part of such development
I could mention in support of other
counselors who share share have shared
their doubts that in the neighboring
Village of Newbold there are houses of
over a million pounds unsold so I wonder
whether there is demand but that's for
the market to decide
uh
I'm I I share the reluctance basically
because it's building in the open
Countryside but I am driven to the
conclusion that the officer has gone
through all the requirements and has
backed up what the agent has said that
this application is policy compliant and
with the degree of reluctance I would
find myself on the side of supporting
the officer
is that a proposal to Grant in line with
the office of recommendation
I will
I will based upon that's my objective
reading of the circumstances and I do it
with reluctance
understood thank you very much councilor
Adam
please
thank you very much um I actually agree
um complete with what councilor Harvey's
just said I think that there are that
the main bonus contention is clearly the
open Countryside and that is outside the
built-up area boundary I
think it's worth noting that the
officer's report does
specifically say that CS 15 16 and as10
are the most important policies for
determining the application but it then
does justify why the weight is adjusted
to suit Our obligation within a national
framework we've been through these
before and there's a lot of things that
I am uncomfortable about I do like the
idea of self builds being self-built but
obviously there are limitations well
open
um opportunities within the the
obligations and the act of parliament to
to see that we do have
um developments as as we're seeing here
within that framework we do have a
deficit
um I've
previously raised concerns about how
that deficit is calculated but I think
there is one
um the issues that I might otherwise
have uh concerns about I think aren't
Subs substantively backed up by evidence
such as the housing need for the village
itself being that there isn't a housing
needs survey
and again affordable housing yes I think
we absolutely do need to see affordable
housing but again this wouldn't be
liable for that anyway
there is reluctance on the on the
father's open Countryside but I can't
see myself
um
finding significant reason to go against
it and the office has clearly been very
diligent in going through all of these
and making sure that there are adequate
conditions to see controls by the
council so I'm quite happy to Second uh
councilor Harvey on that basis noting
reluctance as he did
okay understood thank you very much
indeed does anyone else have anything
they'd like to add council Foreman
please
oh thank you chair
I'm like the rest of my colleagues I'm
uncomfortable with this I the parish
council have objected there are 32
letters of objection from
residents the ward members objected
um and I'm comfortable with the no
affordable housing but
it's finding a reason to go against the
officer so
it's struggling with it at the moment
okay
um I think everyone has had something to
say so unless anyone else has anything
more pressing to say now we'll move to a
vote The Proposal is to Grant in line
with the officer's recommendation made
by councilor Harvey seconded by
councilor Adam could have show of hands
for those in favor please
five five and those against
three and abstentions
one committee therefore resolves to
Grant application
2103775 out this is Atlanta north of
idlicate Road in Halford
okay let's move to our next item
which is application reference
2203627 ful that is land Off shipston
Road in elsmore presenting officer
momentarily will be Malvina attiac
well you know as soon as you're set up
ready to go the floor is yours
all right
good evening everyone
um so um thank you chairman this
application is
um
located near asmore and in the open
Countryside as you can see on this
location plan the site is etched in red
uh here and located off
shiftstone Road
the site area is approximately
1.21 hectares
and here on this slide you can see the
application site within the wider area
so
um what is being proposed planning
permission is sold to erect two barns
for the agricultural purposes
um as you can see here one would be
located close to the highway and one
would be located at the bottom of the
field there
with the arrows indicating the front
elevation of the bar
you can also see on this drawing
um the existing track that was
previously approved under
um anagnet application
and this slide shows the proposed
plan floor plan and elevations of the
buildings they they would have the same
design
as you can see the the barn would have
would have the width of 18 meters and a
depth of 9 meters with the maximum
height
about
5.6 meters
and on this photo you can see the site
looking towards the the field the bottom
of the side
you can also say
part of the existing truck the site ends
were defense
is located to the side
so this Photograph
shows the existing track
as well as the nearby fields in the
background
including the existing hey hey Bales
stored on site
and this slide shows
um
the truck again including the existing
barn on the field
next door which is in a different
ownership
so um this slide shows
the top of the side behind the Hedge
runs ships and Roads and this is where
the first Barn would be located there
and the last slide shows the side axis
German the recommendation is to approve
the application for planning permissions
subject to the conditions as detailed
within the committee report thank you
Arena thank you very much indeed let's
call our next speaker who is councilor
Martin Cole of brailles Parish Council
good evening Council call
and welcome
and the same way as our other speakers
once you're settled and ceases if you
press the button on the right the
microphone will go live you'll have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning the floor is yours
good evening counselors my name is
Martin Cole I am from a farming family
local to brailles I have been farming in
rails for the previous 49 years I with
my family I know this site very well
because I used to farm the adjacent
drybank Farm to it so I know the
capabilities of this land
what it can cannot do with the whole
area
the
the I speak on behalf of brailles Parish
Council
we raise the objection and comments to
this application as follows
the plan is for two buildings 167 square
meters each one-sided one bottom of
field one 200 meters to the top of the
side all this with one plan for the
building
in all my 30 years on brailles Parish
Council I cannot recall an application
you know asking for two buildings at
once this is most unacceptable
especially there are so far apart
I stated a previous application
in July last year was for an agnot for
the hard standing this will be come to
light later on what an agnot is
the feasibility report falls short on
the acreage 1.213 hectares or as I
understand three acres
if you take this hard standing area out
of this acreage you are quite
drastically reduced in the size of the
land available
for the farming area they I understand
they hope to purchase land next to this
but this is uh this is a possibility but
not a fact and you only deal with facts
here tonight Mr chairman
justification statement 2.3 under scale
and citing agricultural building have
been located in close approximity to
existing access
no this just looks but just look at the
plans you'll see for yourself but this
is stated in the statement
under number three the statement the
conclusion States agricultural storage
buildings will be located within
ownership cartilage same statement
different wording equals confusion
uh in the plans and correspondence there
is a correspondence from the cpre which
I believe is your own head of Housing
and planning
the quote they have concerns on this
application com and the comment is
making a mockery of as-10 core strategy
in public reports pack
1904-2023 planning committees quote the
case officer raised a concern that
insufficient information had been
provided to justify the proposed
development given the modest size of the
application site
thank you Mr chairman
spot on time wise thank you very much
Council Cole members do we have any
questions for our counselor please
no in that case Council Cole thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening
okay let's call on that speaker who is
Natasha Silva on behalf of the applicant
good evening Miss silver welcome I think
you know the drill you'll have three
minutes I'll give you 30 second warning
when you're ready the floor's yours
thank you chair
good evening I'm here to speak in
support of this application for two
agricultural buildings at withikum
Fields Farm elsmore I thank officers for
their constructive feedback and
assistance to date and fully endorse
their positive recommendation
the proposed buildings will be steel
portal framed agricultural buildings
with green wall cladding and a gray
proof profile sheet roof these materials
are typical of modern agricultural
buildings and therefore preserve the
distinctive rural character of the site
and surrounding area
post buildings will be located to the
front and rear of the site one will be
used for the storage of agricultural
Machinery equipment necessary for the
operation and maintenance of the land
and the other for the storage of hay and
feed for the livestock
last year the hay had been ruined after
having to be stored outside which caused
it to rot and mold therefore it was
unusable
and a building is needed for the for dry
storage
the applicants are currently in the
process of expanding their family-run
business at wivikum Fields Farm which
includes sheep lamb poultry eggs and hay
sales which all need safe dry storage
for feed and equipment
they are expanding their flock and this
year's spring flock has just been born
they are also planning to have three
cuts of grass yield this year
two smaller buildings were proposed and
said one larger one due to the
applicant's concern that the storing of
dry hay and feel feed together with the
Machinery may not be safe for fire from
a fire safety perspective and they wish
to separate the two to minimize the risk
of extensive fire damage
the existing Farm business is growing
and these buildings are needed to
facilitate its continued expansion
policies cs22 and as10 support
opportunities for business development
and the countryside including farm-based
activities and therefore support the
principle of the proposed agricultural
businesses to grow the business
the parish council objected in part to
the scheme as they are concerned that
the building's May in the future be
converted to housing this was the
objection that was put online
um
however it's worth noting that at
present both class q and full planning
policy require buildings to be in place
for at least 10 years before conversion
is even considered as a possibility
furthermore the application must be
considered as is on the facts as they
stand and therefore theoretical future
applications are irrelevant I would need
to be assessed on their own merits
against a relevant planning policy and
legislation of that type
in summary the officer's report provides
a detailed justification for the
granting of the application
whilst they did raise some initial
concerns additional justification was
provided which has been listed in the
report and then they therefore gave
their positive recommendation
were the agricultural buildings approved
the officer has suggested a number of
conditions be attached to the decision
including addition restricting use to
solely agricultural which we would
happily accept
we hope that this is a straightforward
decision to approve the scheme in line
with the officer's recommendation and
trust that members will agree I'm happy
to answer any questions you may have
thank you
spots on time again thanks very much
councilor Kendall please
thank you chairman good evening
why are the building space so far apart
I understand you say there's concern
about fire but that's quite an extreme
distance isn't it
I understand that I think the applicants
thoughts when they brought it to us was
that they wanted to rather than breaking
up the space by having the buildings
closer together
um but far enough apart for so that they
were still accessible was that by having
them at either side you had a bigger
space in between that could be used for
hay and grass rather than putting one in
the middle and therefore breaking up the
continuation of the line
I'm not sure I quite follow that it has
to be at the extreme ends of the field
though you could ease leave and I know
I'm straying into hypotheticals but
didn't need to be in the middle of the
field I'm just struggling as to why it
it didn't have to be either end that was
the applicant's request when we drew up
the plans that was how they asked for it
to be set out thank you
Council Adam please
thank you uh could you just confirm is
the uh The Landing Compass by the
application site the whole makeup the
whole of the farm as is or is there
additional land outside of what's noted
here which makes up practical farming
land
the land as it currently stands they are
currently in the process of negotiating
to purchase land to
the east of the land but that is
currently as it stands this is a this
basically the start of the business and
they need the buildings to work on what
they have but also with capacity for
going forward as they purchase more land
Council Curtis please
um I think councilor Adam has asked part
of my question so the the sheep and the
chickens and so forth that you referred
to earlier on have all been raised on on
this plot of land
yes they've been they are currently on
the land and more are being purchased
thank you
very good okay Council Jennings please
it's a bit along the same lines so how
many acres did they actually own
yep
it's about it's about three three acres
yeah
and sorry as a final confirmation and
each of these uh 167
square meters two of them 162. 162 sorry
no no no so that's about three three
um 24
square meters in total yes okay thank
you okay Castle Mills please please Jim
good evening
um
is this um a completely new business
because I I I don't know what happened
to the hay
that has reached in the you know in the
past and they didn't have any covering
so this this is a relatively new
business they bought the land two years
ago to start the to start a family run
farming business they got the AG not for
the access and the hard standing first
and then applied for the buildings as
part of a continued
expansion and development of the farm
so it is in its infancy but it is
getting bigger
any other questions
all right thank you
um
do they need such size buildings for the
small acreage of the land
so one building is for Machinery one
building is for hay and feed they have
included capacity for growth in the in
the buildings they are as they get more
land as they get more animals expecting
to need more feed and more space for hay
storage
so getting a building that just
facilitates what's there now would not
help them a year down the line when they
need a bit more space you have to factor
in growth when you're designing
between the buildings uh is hard
standing going from one building to the
other
the buildings are so far apart is the
hard standing going from one building to
another building
well not quite it goes part way it goes
part way at the site this was usually
this was originally proposed just for
Access further into the site
um with the building at the top being
used the Machinery that will go on to go
up and down the field anyway therefore
it didn't need
yeah and a specific access point
councilgenics
that's one one more question
um the elevations
um is the is The Barn at the bottom is
it on a is it on a flat land or is it on
a slope
did you put your microphone on please uh
yes it is they're relatively flat the
land there isn't much of an incline at
all as you go from front to back okay
thank you
any other questions members
nope okay thank you very much your time
contribution
right so it's cool for our last speaker
on this item who is cancer Wally Hopkins
again
welcome back
oh absolutely not uh you know the drill
five minutes 30 second warning when
you're sat comfortable ready to go the
floor's yours
applications such as these are very
numerous and so are applications to
convert former agricultural buildings
into houses under the couq system
applications like that must be granted
applications are then applicants are
then apt to change these permissions to
apply for their bounds bounds not to be
converted but to be exchanged for
conventional homes which make a total
mockery of policy as10 the core strategy
and will and do make a total mockery of
planning committees such as this it is
therefore essential that permissions for
agricultural buildings should not be
granted unless you can be absolutely
sure that they are essential to the
applicant's needs and no larger than
strictly necessary this land totals two
and a half acres not three acres due to
the permission previously granted for
hard standing which has already been
developed this land will therefore only
support a maximum of 10 sheep as one
acre can raise three or four four sheep
the field is unsuitable for hailage of
any sort or for raising livestock for
more than five months of the year is
simply too wet there will be no straw to
store from this land and 10 sheep do not
eat two bounds worth of food a year or
need an entire Barn of equipment to
service them the applicant owns just
three acres they are not Farmers they
have not provided any business plan for
their supposed Farm we've heard today of
a farm being mentioned a name given to
it known in brales has ever heard of it
the applicant's name is a wig wigram
nobody's heard of wigram the farmers but
they've heard of wigram groundscapes and
Landscape of taiso but they're involved
in construction engineering and civil
engineering we just don't know who these
people are no farmer needs two barns of
this gargantuan proportions for three
acres of land other businesses however
might make excellent use of two
considerable sized barns which will each
measure 167 meters squared especially if
they are linked with hard standing as
per the previous uh successful
application and pictures this is an
audacious application and in the
justification statement the agent states
that these two bounds are needed to
serve the existing agricultural business
there is no existing agricultural
business and to provide sufficient
provision for it to expand over the
coming years there is no land either for
sale or likely to become available
I say come back when you need it come
back when you've proven that you are
actually farmers who want to farm the
land the need for these barns is like
buying a twin pram before a baby is even
being concerned conceived I am also
astounded that the agricultural
statement says it's not in the green
belt it is however in open Countryside
the whole of brailles and long Compton
is a picturesque rural area these bounds
will also be able to be seen from the
Cotswold protected landscape area and
that is not a matter that can be
dismissed as the views and Vistas from
the CPL are of equal importance these
bonds are positioned in close proximity
to the CPL it is shameful that this
application has been brought before you
clearly there is only one farming expert
in this room associated with this
application and that's the parish
councilor councilor Martin Cole who at
the age he is has been farming in
Braille for 49 years in addition Mr Cole
has asked me to tell you that this
application doesn't have a waste
disposal form attached to it which is a
requirement for all Farmers with any
development I am wary of the lack of
understanding of the fundamental
requirements and detailed requirements
of a business plan I continually
forgotten about and yes farmers do need
to provide these too this application is
taking us for fools there is no
justification for these buildings on
this site it is not a farm nine sheep do
not make it a viable business so I say
nice try Sheldon Bosley and Mr wigram
but we've got the measure of your real
intentions and it certainly isn't
farming thank you
thank you very much indeed do we have
any questions members
Council Curtis just one thank you thank
you very much cancer that was very
informative you
mentioned something about waste disposal
that you said should be part of any
agriculture could you just give us a
little more detail on that it was um I
lost it in Translation I'm afraid to be
fair if you need those details you'll
need to call
The Farmer in the in the room to the
table because he will have more in-depth
knowledge of that
sorry it is a requirement for all
Farmers to have a waste disposal
um statement and permission for that
disposal because farming
um if has a lot of plastic waste
associated with it so they all have to
be registered for that is my is my
understanding and that should have been
part of this application you can't be a
farmer Red Tractor approved Etc in order
if you don't if you don't have that it
is missing from this and should have
really formed part of the the business
plan as well because getting rid of
waste is part of is part of a cost of
running a farm as I said I think what
we'll do the other the the parish
councilor who is a farmer knows more
about that he just didn't have time to
in his speech to talk to you about thank
you councilwale Evans I think what we'll
do is get our planets to give you a
definitive from a planning perspective
and planning law that ultimately is what
we're looking at do we have any other
questions members
no councilor Huggins thank you very much
for your time contribution team
okay we were like no four questions of
our officers I think we might have a
question for you
I'm not aware that a waste disposal
plan is required on an application of
this nature it may well be that there
are separate Waste Management
regulations outside of the planning
remit which I I anticipate is actually
what what is required in that respect
castlegenics
two questions for you
um
was a business plan provided stroke is
one needed and the next question was
um have they submitted evidence for the
need
for
bonds of that size
um
for the amount of land they have
right and do they need to provide that
um so in terms of the business plan
normally it is not required
to submit Twitter planning application
although I'm aware that in case of AG
notes uh
the assessment of a magnet application
includes
justification of the need and the need
must be
um
current not projected whereas in the
case of a planning application
applicants can submit
applications for development including
taking into account their projected
needs if that makes sense so
in this case I guess that's why the
requirement to there is no requirement
to submit a business plan or
anything like that
just to add to that
um within policy as10 the if you have it
in front of you
um part e of as10 require in respect of
a dwelling and it says a dwelling that
forms part of the conversion of a
building in the open Countryside where
it's ancillary to a business and is
necessary to ensure the efficient and
secure operation of the business if you
then move down to the development
management considerations which is part
six that's where it refers to the need
for a business plan to be submitted it's
not in relation to part o which is what
this this application has been
considered under
um cancel out of the next please thank
you I think
possibly might be covered by your
previous answer but I was going to ask
the I suppose key differences between
agnor and full and why this is not a
agnot and is a full application
um you might want to elaborate
so
um in this case
um
as you can see the application site is
quite small and it is because
um a larger holding was
divided I assume and
Parcels of land sold off to different
owners and at this point these small
Parcels of land became like separate
Holdings
but because on The Wider holding there
was I've not granted and erected as you
could see on the photos
to decide there was this small barn
um
to to the West uh because of that
because on The Wider holding a barn was
erected under diagonal application the
applicants could not exercise the same
route to apply for a barn
Council Mills please
Mr chairman uh now we know the um
you've got one bomb one and one on the
other end for that stripping
in between barns that's all agricultural
land is it yes yes everything so
could could not the barns be built side
by side what was the reason for them
which will make more sense to me uh so I
think
um
um the applicants were actually that was
the agent who explained that the reason
to separate the two was to keep
um
um the hay and the feed separately from
the Machinery
um and the reason behind that is fire
safety
um because
[Music]
um
I guess it makes sense that the two
barns are separated and there is at this
like a considerable distance because in
the case of fire of the hay barn for
example the barn with the Machinery uh
would be less likely to be destroyed if
that makes sense
thank you
okay
yes
just on that point obviously officers
would only ask for amendments to an
application where we consider that there
there is a harm or an issue that
resolves resolution and we feel that
those amendments would overcome that if
I draw your attention to page 55 of the
report where we've considered the
landscape and character impacts that
outlines why we consider that
Arrangement acceptable so we wouldn't
necessarily have had to have got into a
situation of asking for justification
for for the separation distances of
those two buildings
Curtis please
thank you
um
I believe earlier on Marina you
indicated that or it had been naked by
somebody sorry that before any change of
use could be considered this would have
to be used as an Agri or these would
have to be used as agricultural
buildings for 10 years
are there any exceptions to that or
would it were we minded to Grant this
application would it be absolutely
guaranteed that there could be no change
of use for 10 years
I I appreciate why you were asking that
question but obviously from our
perspective
um and from your perspective you are
making an assessment of of the
application as submitted and it wouldn't
necessarily be appropriate
um to to think about what what would
happen later on
um because obviously if if a prior
approval application was to be submitted
or a full planning application for the
conversion would be submitted we would
have to consider that application at
that time it wouldn't be appropriate for
us to be making an assessment of that
situation at this point
and of course the national policies
could change in 10 years so it's worth
bearing that in mind
councilor Harvey I've been patient
um
two questions could the officers confirm
that
the uh
who makes an application is not a
planning matter
I whether somebody is a farmer or a
landscaper or whatever they do and
whoever they are is irrelevant from a
planning point of view it's question
number one
question number two
the
the window through which this
application is supported in relation to
as10
is as10a which quoted in the in the
report says a building or structure
related to agriculture Horticulture and
Forestry where it is required
for such purposes
was any thought given to or is there any
case for an Agricultural consultant's
view being sought given the doubt that's
been raised between the scale of the
proposal and and the three acre Barn the
three acre field I'm just I would feel
more comfortable if there was a farming
expert who had said whatever he wants to
say that we could then take into account
so in respect of your first question
could you just repeat that for me so I
make sure they answer it correctly uh
who who makes an application is not a
planning matter no no not generally and
and generally
um government guidance discourages sort
of personal permissions where you would
in effect condition it to that person so
no we we wouldn't you wouldn't
necessarily take into account who is
applying for the application
um and in respect to
um your second question with regarding
to to getting an independent assessment
we don't generally on applications like
this but certainly
um policy as10 in the in the development
management considerations does refer to
an independent assessment of the case
will be on undertaken on behalf of the
council where necessary so obviously as
the decision makers that is for you to
to determine that policy as as you as
you wish
thank you very much okay are we all done
with points clarification councilor
Jennings isn't
so on from what you've just said could
we put it on as a condition
that a
um assessment was done by an
agricultural expert
so we Grant it subject to
I don't consider that that would make
the tests because ultimately if you were
putting a condition on of that nature if
the consultant came back and they felt
that they hadn't demonstrated or or the
the you know the the business case or or
the the scale of the development was uh
not
um in alignment with the the operations
on that site then ultimately we've
already approved the development so you
wouldn't necessarily be able to rescind
it so if you feel that an assessment of
that nature is required to enable you to
make the decision it should be
undertaken before the decision is made
in that in that circumstance
thank you um has everyone else finished
with the points clarification we can
move into debate who would like to kick
us off
Council Curtis yeah thanks Gerald kicks
off
at the very least
I would like to see this application
or any decision deferred
until we have further Evidence looking
at page 54 of the report
um I think it might be enlightening for
the committee to see what the statement
from the applicants was
the the other evidence that's there and
then looking at page 197 in the core
strategy does say where planning
Commissioners required applicants will
have to demonstrate functional need for
the proposed building an independent
assessment of the case will be
undertaken on behalf of the council
where necessary so I think at the very
least until we've got further
information I'd like to
either refuse or at least defer any
decision thank you is that a proposal to
defer so that a report can be undertaken
yes I'll be quite happy to do that I
will happily second that
um simply on the basis that the scale of
that field for the scale of the two
bonds the separations of et cetera et
cetera et cetera makes me feel a little
uncomfortable so I want to have a
definitive response from an expert in
the matters to say that do you know what
this is justifiable given the
circumstances so I'm perfectly happy to
second that does anyone else want to
speak yeah
yes thank you chair
um to me this doesn't add up
there is no way you're going to fill one
of these barns with the hay off three
acres of ground
um it I would classify this as a small
holding not agricultural
and I don't think it is quite right
there's something in my mind fishy about
it thank you thank you I think that's
the purpose of getting the report so
um unless anyone else desperately wants
to speak I think we can move we've got a
proposal that's been seconded let's move
to a vote The Proposal is to uh defer a
decision so that we can get a full
independent assessment done for the
reasons that we've obviously set out
could I have Council yes could I just
say that we we as well as the
independent assessment we also see this
further information that the statement
from the applicants justifying the need
so we have signs of that additional
information yeah
that should be on the planning
application so it's available so you'll
be able to log on and get that I think
the deferral for the for the report is
is the is well Justified and appropriate
um okay so let's have a show of hands
please for those in favor of deferable
for reasons given
that is unanimous so committee therefore
is obviously defer application
2203627 ful land Off shipston Road in
elsmore right we will move to our next
item which is application
2300121 full Primrose house in
Smithfield now our presenting officer is
in fact going to be Alison Willis
tonight and I'm going to make myself
vacant and hand over to the very capable
councilor Kendall
right good evening everyone right so we
then moved to iPhone 7 application
reference
2300121 ful Primrose house nine the hill
Kingsland Centerville this is then for
the erection for carport including store
presenting officer I'll just slow down a
bit
cool
already
presenting officer Alison Willis over to
you foreign
thank you
um
so the application site Primrose house
is located Southwest from the main built
up Parish of snitterfield to the south
of the a46 approximate location shown by
the black dot
so the site is located off King's Lane
and is located with the green belt
within the green belt and it's in the
special landscape area
the application proposes the erection of
a carport and store this application is
a resubmission of an earlier application
22 forward slash zero zero zero seven
four slash full that was refused and
very recently dismissed appeal
this is an aerial view of the site
showing the approximate application
boundary in red
the location is semi-rural with open
Countryside on all sides apart from
immediate Neighbors on Kings Lane
so the existing site is comprised of a
large house with Gardens to the front of
the area
if you can see my cursor
this is the house
Gravel Drive Gardens to the front lawn
the house previously benefited from a
garage on the site located immediately
north of the dwelling which is this
rectangle here if you can see my cursor
the garage has since been changed into
ancillary accommodation through the
approval of a retrospective planning
permission and an additional planning
permission has been granted for a
building to link the ancillary auxiliary
building to the main house
this permission has yet to be
implemented I understand
so the proposed garage and store the
subject of this application
is to be located north and forward of
the main house as shown by this gray
rectangle here
shaded
not only Not only would the new garage
be forward of the principal elevation of
the main house it's also separated from
the ancillary accommodation the former
garage by approximately five meters
so this slide shows the proposed design
of the garage and store it would measure
9.6 meters in length by 6.5 meters in
width with a ridge height of 2.9 meters
and is comprised of three
parking spaces and one enclosed storage
Bay at the end the proposed building is
open on three sides with a storage Bay
being enclosed
so this is the this this slide shows the
floor plan
with the store at the end
so this
photograph is taken from the road
looking outside from outside on the road
into the site
it shows the location of the new garage
and it would be visible from the road
in kind of this area
this is the proposed location of the
garage in the store approximately where
the white car is
the picture is taken from halfway up the
applicant's driveway the location is
currently open and separate from the
existing built form
this is another review of the proposed
location of the development the picture
is taken from the front door of the main
house you can see how far forward and
separated would be from the principal
elevation of the main house
that's the end of the presentation Mr
chairman there are no updates for this
application
and the recommendation is that the
application be refused for the two
reasons detailed in the report
thank you
thank you Allison okay we go to our
first Speaker which is councilor Karine
Elliott from She's the vice chairman of
Centerville Parish Council if you'd like
to come forward
hello welcome
right so once you've made yourself
comfortable you'll have three minutes to
speak and if you've remain seated for
any questions at the end press the
button on the right so the microphone
comes on and I'll give you a warning at
30 seconds if that's all right okay over
to you
thank you chairman
previous success application
20020414 is relevant here as under this
application the existing guide was
converted to a single story and silly
accommodation to provide suitable living
space for elderly parents this left the
applicants without a garage and as a
result an unsuccessful application two
two zero zero zero seven full was made
to construct a large garage which the
parish council did object to
at the request of the applicants the
parish council subsequently conducted a
site visit to discuss the applicant's
plans and to consider the parish
council's concerns
taking into account the parish council's
concerns this new application represents
a significant Improvement to the
previous one the length has actually
been increased from a the length that
has actually been increased from 8.05
meters to 9.6 meters however the impact
has been considerably lessened as the
ridge height is reduced from 5.4 meters
to 2.9 meters the width from 9 meters to
6 meters and the overall massing of the
car part is reduced the carport is
reduced by 23 cubic meters it is open
sided apart from the rear where there is
a Secure Storage Unit the structure will
be subservient to the main dwelling and
is clearly just a structure to shelter
cars and provide Secure Storage
there has been much discussion on the
location of the structure and whether it
is within five meters of the main
buildings
the LPA have determined that the only
the corn of the structures in five
meters of the main building it must
therefore principally be assessed on
whether the structure affects the
openness of the green belt rather than
under NDP B3 neighborhood design
guidelines
Greenbelt legislation exists to ensure
that the countryside is safe is
safeguarded from encroachment
the new carport is situated near to the
main building and therefore is not
encouraging into the large plot on which
these buildings sit the carport is not
visible from the road when the main
gates you saw the picture but when the
main gates closed it's not visible and
it's not visible to neighboring
properties
the parish council there considers that
there is limited harm to the openness of
the green belt the new car part however
will protect the cars from overhead
damage from trees and birds required
provides Secure Storage and vehicle
electric charging facilities which the
applicant has agreed to install
special circumstances existed to convert
the existing gauge to provide suitable
living space for elderly parents and
therefore a replacement by way of a
carport is not unreasonable
however if members agree to Grant the
parish council request which is
legislation of the electric charging
point is made a condition of this
application to mitigate to any perceived
harm to the green belt
well within your time thank you very
much any questions please from the
committee
not at all in that case thank you very
much for your time this evening okay
thank you we can call our next speaker
Daniel gidney the applicant please
foreign
rules apply so whenever you're ready the
button on the right is to start and I'll
give you a warning at 30 seconds if
that's okay
whenever you're ready over to you
I'd like to thank the committee for
giving me an opportunity to speak in
support of the application for a Timber
open-sided carpool
to provide some background we were asked
to withdraw this application resubmit
and apply for a legal certificate
including statutory declarations to
evidence that the proposed development
the land that it was on was lawful which
we have done
I'd like to show that we have special
circumstances to support this
application and that there is no
material harm to the green belt as
referenced by the officer's Report with
the use of the word modest
we were granted planning consent over
two years ago to convert our single
garage for social care reasons for our
parents who are aged from late 70s to
91. one of whom is disabled
to enable them to have Extended Stays
without having to use stairs and to have
both buildings connected by a link
since the pandemic both sets of parents
have spent and are spending more time
with us at overnight stays as we provide
them support and ultimately potentially
live with us
core strategy 10 does identify potential
exceptions for green belt development
which includes a small scale development
which meets a housing employment or
other need identified by the local
community this potentially could include
social care
the consequence though of creating a
social care Space by converting our
single garage which just to correct the
officer it hasn't been converted it's
still there would be to lose storage and
covered parking
This concerns us as we once suffered in
the powers from bird excrement
significantly damaging a carbonate and
more recently high wind a tree fell onto
my car which took two people's
substantial time to clear before the car
could be used to get to work
please see photograph 4 as was sent
through in advance
I think still pause for a second I have
them here but we did send them well in
advance of the time
what do you have I'm going to ask do we
have any any of that right
um
who did you send them to the committee
email that we were asked to send to and
they were sent on Saturday which was
well in in time
I have I have one copy here okay well
give us a second we'll just see if we
can find them if they if they did arrive
in the right time then we'll be able to
show them it will take us a couple of
moments to sort that out just bear with
us okay and I have paused your time
don't worry
all right
welcome back everybody okay we've now
sorted all all the presentations out and
we're ready to start up you have a total
of one uh sorry about uh we've had one
minute 53 so you've got just over a
minute left one minute ten seconds
though thereabouts okay I'll still give
you the warning at 30 seconds just in
case all right over to you
so this was what I said about the photo
four with the trees uh falling on my car
so after constructive advice from our
Ward councilor and Parish Council we
revised the application considerably to
a very simple and more crucially
open-sided Timber kit please see the
next photograph
the small carport is not a building in
the traditional sense as referred to in
the office report and could almost be
perceived as a temporary structure in
its visuality
additionally we are not overlooked At
All by and enable the public realm and
then you can bring up the next two
photos please
the application also commits us to
environmental elements to soften the
structures features 30 seconds
appropriately to blend into its
immediate surroundings to mitigate any
harm to the green belt this would
include planting and using climbers
around Timber posts and structure and we
commit to adding a water button electric
car charging point the new simple
structure is also within five meters of
our existing building the office's
report confirms the carport is a
domestic adjunct and we believe should
be considered a small scale addition my
wife and I are not developers we've
lived in our home for over 15 years and
in summary we'd like you to reflect on
our special circumstances providing
support to elderly parents we've
listened and revised the plans
accordingly
and we would ask you thank you for your
time and consideration thank you
two seconds over I think we'll allow it
okay right committee do we have any
questions
thank you very much for your time as
well tonight
means we go to our final speaker on this
application award member Peter Richards
um
it's five minutes sorry you know the
routine you've got five minutes to speak
on this I'll give you a warning in the
last 30 seconds whenever you're ready
thank you chairman members you've heard
from both the applicant and the parish
council now who have set out the merits
of this proposal and why they think it
should be granted I'm in full support of
their comments you'll see on page 65 of
your agenda pack that the case officer
has detailed what is and what isn't
inappropriate development in the green
belt specifically he has stated that
case law confirms that new outbuildings
can be accepted as an extension to
buildings provided that they form a
normal domestic adjunct
he goes on to say that in the recent
appeal decision the inspector found that
the carport and store could be
considered to be a normal domestic
adjunct as such concluding that it
should be judged as an extension to the
existing dwelling so in principle
therefore the proposed carport can be
considered an extension to the dwelling
and would therefore not be an
inappropriate development in the green
belt subject to its size and scale
so ultimately this application hinges on
whether the proposed carport is of small
scale or not I believe that it is
the original proposal which was
dismissed at appeal was for a
significantly larger carport with
enclosed store and only open on two
sides The Proposal before you now is a
much reduced scheme with a lower pitch
height and depth than the previous
application great care has been given by
the applicant to ensure that the
proposal has limited to no impact on the
openness of the green belt
there is no definition of what is or
isn't small scale in the mppf OR in our
core strategy historically a guide of 30
has been used for dwellings in the
Greenbelt however this is a guide it is
not a hard and fast rule Smithfield's
NDP does state that extensions to
buildings shall not normally exceed 30
of the volume of the building as it
existed at the time the green belt was
established or when it was built if
later
the purpose of this policy is to prevent
vast extensions to properties within the
village which as you know is covered by
Greenbelt the word normally allows for
reasonable movement and common sense to
be applied in giving their full support
to this application I would assert that
the parish council considers that this
policy in their NDP has in fact been met
so when comparing other carports and
garages garage extensions along King's
Lane to their host dwelling and then
comparing those of to this proposal I do
not consider that this carport to be out
of character over or of such a scale
that would be damaging to the green belt
the street scene or to Warrant a refusal
for its size and scale when compared to
its own host dwelling and finally if I
can address the second reason for
refusal on your agenda pack which is for
insufficient details for climate
checklist
I suspect this is Administrative issue
that can be overcome and so if you agree
with my position on the principle and
the size and scale of the proposed you
can move to Grant Subject to the
satisfactory completion of the climate
change checklist and indeed we have done
that before which you'll know from the
application that we'll be hearing after
this one
so with full Parish Council support Ward
member support and no objections from
Neighbors or statutory consultees I urge
you to Grant permission subject to the
satisfactory completion of the climate
checklist for the reasons I have set out
thank you Jim
well well within your five minutes any
questions for the ward member please
no relatively straightforward thank you
very much Council Richards
okay committee points of clarification
do we have any questions for the
officers
Council Adam
thank you
um the report notes that
um
the existing house has been extended and
increased approximately 80 in relation
to the originally
um approved replacement Cottage what
what would the total increase be
um if considering this an extension as
well
in terms of percentage would
see what I mean so the total cumulative
increase of the proposed development
would be 125 percent
so the
uh appeal that was just dismissed the
total cumulative increase
of the that previous proposal was 130
percent
so it's the newer the the more recent
um
uh proposal is wider
but it's long uh sorry it's if you can
yeah can you see on here
um it's not as tall
but in terms of
the new proposal is longer but narrower
so in terms of
the cubic volume
the
first application was 190 meters cubed
and the second the current application
is 167 meters cubed
so it is a bit less but it's not a huge
amount less
any other questions or points
clarification
okay let's go to the debate he wants to
kick us off
Council Mills
yes thanks Mr chairman
um
when I looked at this application I
thought it's not um
it looks okay to me but then I thought
well the applicant has created his own
problem
by taking away his garage and then it
bounces back that um the reason he did
this to look after his um
I would leave in-laws or parents
um so
um
I go back to my original thoughts it
I can't see it causing a considerable
harm
um
these constructions of these open
garages are quite well used and I think
I think it fits in with the
with a
with the content so with the house
rather so um
I'm at the moment
um
think of going thinking of going against
yourself as recommendation Mr chairman
but I'll um I'll see what everybody else
has to say thank you
anyone else
counselor Adam
my thoughts generally on the design are
but it does seem to sort of fit and
there is no overwhelming harm let's say
the thing that does concern me is the in
this case somewhat incremental increase
in the
uh total amount of extension that the
properties had and 100 to the ward
members point that you know that
there's the guide being 30 125
isn't exactly within the same
um realm so generally speaking I don't
have a fundamental issue with the design
I do have an issue with that amount of
increase being contrary to policy and
being significant
um I mean I think some of the words the
war member used was but you know it's
not a vast extension it in and of itself
isn't but that total amount is the bit
that worries me which why I asked I I'm
a bit stuck there I must admit because
design is you know one aspect of it but
whether in terms of solid planning
reasons to go against the officer's
recommendation that's kind of what I'm
coming up short against in light of that
amount that's my feeling at the moment
um I won't make any proposition at the
moment either
thank you I've got cancer Jennings next
um obviously there are two reasons to go
against this I think
um I think there are second reason
um
can certainly be
overcome by a condition
the first one
are there any special circumstances well
we don't need special circumstances if
we regard it as small scale
um
obviously the inspector
turned down a previous
application but again we have to judge
each application on its own merits the
previous application
I think the height of it
would certainly be the issue
with visibility the fact that it's
almost been halved in in height
um makes me a lot more sympathetic
towards it
um
I think you can
sort of guess which way I'm going on
this that I've kind of starting to think
that this is small scale and therefore
would be acceptable but again I'll let
everyone else through there and two
pence worth in
okay thank you Council Foreman thank you
um I agree with councilor Jennings I am
sympathetic with this application
the um
application that got refused it's now
being reduced in size it's now open on
three sides not two as it was before and
I also think we can take into account
the special circumstances the parents
and the in-laws so
I am going along the lines of going
against the officer
at the moment
thank you Council Curtis
thank you very much I'm just agreeing
with the last last two speakers really
um also we have Ward member and Parish
Council support it's with the gates are
closed it's not visible from the highway
I can't really see any material harm so
I yes thank you I would probably go
against the uh
thank you very much yeah looking at it I
don't have an issue with this it's it's
not tall so it's not standing out in the
countryside and there is a quite a large
hedge behind it so it's obscured it's
obscured from the road so to me it
doesn't spoil the openness of the green
belt
okay thank you thank you right no one's
making a proposition I'll do it
um I'm in agreement with everything
you've said so far
um I find this to be and by the way I
think the fact that the applicants have
gone away they've looked at this have
come back with a different application
one that is I think significantly
smaller I think that makes a huge
difference to me significantly smaller
this is a I found to be a very small
scale development in yes in the green
belt but nevertheless I've had to be
very small scale I don't think there'll
be any harm to the street scene or to
the setting and the openness of the
green belt therefore I will propose that
we go against officer recommendation and
Grant this application do I have a
second
uh well I I think couch Jennings hand
was up first but you spoke first I'm
going to go with that counselor Jennings
just a second do you want to speak on it
Council Jennings um I would I'm happy to
second that um obviously subject to
um climate change checklist
well I would be happy with that as well
does anybody else wish to speak on this
at this point
okay I'll go to the offices Emily you
happy with what you've heard so far
should I say are you content with our
reasons to go against officer
recommendation it's not are you happy
from from
just to revert back to some of the
comments in the inspector made in the
appeal which is material
um he says however and more
significantly taking into account of the
previous extensions at the property The
Proposal would be around 130 larger than
the original dwelling
so the inspector has considered that
it's significant to to consider the the
cumulative
um extensions obviously that's material
but you can attach
whatever weight you wish to attach to
that but I just wanted to draw reference
to that comment within the appeal
decision
um before you move forward with your
with your vote
um in terms of attaching a condition
um that wouldn't necessarily be a
problem would you want it as a condition
for the climate change checklist to be
submitted
um prior to commencement
yes
in terms of your comments regarding the
inspectors appraisal of this so noted
let's go to a vote shall we all those in
favor of granting the application please
show
oh hold on
the rest of the conditions apologies put
your hands back down just go through the
rest of the we do need the standard set
of conditions don't we apologize I'm out
of practice
okay just standard conditions so a
three-year time limit for commencement
um
development to be carried second
condition development in uh
to be developed and approved to be
carried out in accordance with
um the submit plans and drawings
um
and then another condition for external
facing and roofing materials
prior to use I guess
oh yes in accordance with
um
that was in accordance with the approved
drawings
and then
uh fourth condition carport and store
hereby permitted shall only be used for
parking and storage uses ancillary to
the enjoyment of the main dwelling known
as nine the hill Primrose house it
should not be used for any other use
than to which the permission relates and
no separate cartilage shall be created
plus the fifth condition climate change
checklist prior to commencement
thank you for that I completely agree
far too eager tonight okay well we're
happy with the conditions and Council
Jennings as the secondary you're also
happy okay but in that case we can go to
the vote all those in favor of granting
the application please show
those against and abstentions
one thank you therefore the committee uh
resolves to Grant application reference
two three zero zero one two one full and
I can thank
okay thank you very much councilor
Kendall for that we will move to our
next item which is application reference
2201005 ful it's Corner Cottage the
Green in schnitter field
um are presenting officer is Charlotte
Dix Charlotte over to you
thank you chair
so the application site is within the
center of the village of schnitterfield
the application site is washed over by
the West Midlands green belts and is
within the designated special landscape
area the property is also cited within
flood zone three
the application property is on a
prominent Corner location on the corner
of the green and Smith Lane the property
is entirely within the conservation area
which is denoted by the purple line
here we have a photo showing the
application property property centrally
within the photo showing the prominent
Corner location
so this proposal is seeking full
planning permission for the erection of
a two-story front and side extension
here on this slide we have the submitted
existing and proposed front elevations
with the proposed at the bottom of the
screen
this would illustrate the property as
viewed from the green to the front
this slide shows the existing and
proposed elevational details with the
elevations as viewed from the garden on
the left hand side and from the drive
elevation on the right hand side so the
garden elevates elevation is as would be
seen from Smith Lane
here we can see the existing and
proposed floor plans
this includes details of the internal
layout changes proposed
we've got the ground floor plans on the
left hand side with the first floor
plans on the right hand side
so this photo is taken stood from the
front on the green looking southwards
towards the application property the
extension would be cited on the left
hand side of the screen
here we're site well we're looking from
School Road looking South westwards
towards the property and The Wider
setting the proposed extension would be
cited in the Gap centrally in the photo
offices consider that the proposal fails
to comply with the development plan
owing to the sighting the design of the
proposed extensions and concerns
relating to flooding members will
remember that the item was deferred from
the 21st of December 2020 2022 committee
to allow the submission of the
information relating to flooding and
climate change
whilst the climate change information
which has been submitted this week is
acceptable the flood risk assessment is
not sufficient to assure offices that
the development would be acceptable in
flood risk terms
I refer you to the update within the
update sheet relating to the information
received this week and the updated
recommendation
so the recommendation is to refuse the
application based on reasons one and
three are set out on pages 81 and 82 of
the agenda thank you thank you very much
let's call our first speaker on this
item who is councilor current Elliott
again
as usual you'll have three minutes I'll
give you 30 second warning before your
time is up when you're ready floor's
yours
thank you Chad
the parish council were very surprised
to see this planning application listed
for the committee again I actually I
actually presented at committee on 21st
December 22 and the support was
unanimous to Grant the application
from what I remember the issue of
flooding was only flagged upon the
knights as a last minute update by the
planning officer who had belatedly
checked the online EA flood mats and had
hastily ascertain the property in flood
zone 3 high risk and advise the
committee accordingly unfortunately
since the major flood works on the cover
were completed in 2017 and this new
covert runs through the front garden of
this property the ehei has still not
updated these online Maps the LPA are
aware of this
the parish council refers to the
planning officers committee report on
2002203-4 Smithfield Methodist Church
and I quote drainage and flood risk page
10. the site is located entirely within
flood zone 1 lowest risk of flooding
recent remodeling work by the aea shows
the majority of the site is include Zone
1. the information has not been updated
on the EA's external Maps but has been
confirmed by correspondence Corner
Cottage is directly opposite the
Methodist Church the corner Cottage
postcode is cv37 ojg
the Methodist Church is cv37 ojh it is
virtually in the same place
if you enter the Methodist Church
postcode in the current online EA Maps
as I did today it still shows as high
risk which illustrates that
frustratingly the online maps have not
been updated in this area since the
completion of the covet
it is a Pity that the LPA did not obtain
correspondence from the EA regarding
Corner Cottage instead of relying on the
out-of-day EA Maps
in addition with our local knowledge we
are aware that this area is not flooded
since the Culvert was completed in 2017.
there was also the fact that the
extension is less than 250 meters
squared which means it falls into the
lower risk category development as
defined by the mppf even if it was in
flood zone 3 which it isn't this has
been confirmed by correspondence stated
13th of April 23 from Stephen Locke
Associates environmental and planning
consultants and recently sent to the RPA
on the basis of the above the parish
council considers that flood risk
assessment is not required and when
evolving up applicants an additional
unnecessary expense
we understand that an acceptable updated
climate change Matrix has now been
submitted to the lpo
it is disappointing and battling that
these matters could not have been dealt
with between the applicants and the LPA
rather than referring the whole
application back to this committee
thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions for our Parish
Council
no I have one you mentioned the planning
reference number for the Methodist
Church I didn't quite catch it could you
give it to me again please yes
it is
yeah
2-02203 forward slash full
and I've also got a copy of the um
extract of the um officers report which
we refers to that I will ask our primary
manager to find that she has digital
copy right in front of her so we will
I'm I think you might be having a point
of clarification later on today thank
you very much for your time and
contribution this evening thank you
okay let's call our next speaker on the
item who is Lynn Wallace on behalf of
the applicant
good evening and thank you very much for
your patience
and the same way as our previous
speakers you'll have three minutes I'll
give you 30 second warning before your
time is up otherwise when you're seated
come from ready to go press the button
on the right and the floor is yours
good evening everybody
um much of which I'm going to say has
already been stated by councilor Elliott
but just to reiterate in the meeting
last December the committee voted
unanimously to allow the small extension
which will accommodate a growing family
safely by moving the stairs and an extra
bedroom for the youngest the family have
lived there since 2002 so it's very much
part of the village
it was as Council Elliot said added last
minute at the planning meeting regarding
the climate report and the flood risk
report the climate report has now been
accepted
in the planning letter that was sent to
the architect it did not state a time
scale for getting this information and
it has proved incredibly difficult to
get any information from the environment
agency who say they have a major backlog
due to covid but then the report their
map hasn't been updated since 2013.
it was a surprise also to be relisted
for a committee meeting taking up
valuable time of the committee members
and with the proposal to refuse
it surely would have been more prudent
had the planning department contacted us
direct to find out where we were up to
especially as they are aware that the
environment agency have not updated the
maps since 2013.
the delay in updating the maps
um sorry and we could have explained to
them how hard we had been trying to get
all of this information even stranger
that planning was granted for the
Methodist Church opposite corner Cottage
it was accepted by planning that due to
the Culvert work done in 2017 that the
flood risk was now low its state
evidence was provided but it's not
available on the planning application
well not that I could find
the planning department have now
confirmed that the minor adjustments for
the climate report were accepted but
despite a report from the expert flood
consultant Stephen Locke stating the
flood risk is now low and under planning
practice guidance National framework has
detailed on page 48 of the framework
that because the extension is less than
250 square meters it is deemed to be
very low risk category and that a full
flood resessment is not required
the extensive work done to the Culvert
in 2017 at a cost of 2.7 million was
done to remove the risk of flooding from
the brook and the surface water to the
village and it has been a great success
in addition Corner Cottage has now added
a permeable driveway a raised level so
that the pavement is low as you could
probably see in those pictures and added
a service drain so I really hope the
committee can take all of this into
consideration and Grant full planning
as well as thank you very much indeed
members do we have any questions for
Miss Wallace
no and that all councilor Mills does
please thank you um on the flooding do
you say it's low risk now is it
could you put your microphone on when
you speak please the flood report from
the consultant says it was low risk and
also it's considered low risk because of
the size of the extension and the fact
that there's been no update since 2013
from the environment agency
um and I have a picture here but I
didn't send it through which shows
the raised curb and the drain so that
the driveway is now a lot higher and all
of this is now permeable so any surface
waterfall in there would Now drain
through and all of this has been done
since 2017 so the flood risk listed is
completely wrong and it was accepted for
the Methodist Church that it was now a
flood risk one and Corner Cottage is
literally opposite it so it doesn't make
sense
very much thank you to anyone else with
any questions
no I just want to thank you very much
for your time and your patience this
evening
okay we have no more speakers on this
item so points of clarification could
you please tell us whether
what
I was going first
[Laughter]
um I've lost my train of thought
um could you confirm whether we have
indeed had confirmation from the EA that
this is now flood of risk one and I
believe that confirmation is likely to
be attached to the Methodist Church
application
foreign
looking at the reports for the reference
that was mentioned earlier on at the
Methodist Church it does State
um that the site is located almost
entirely within flood zone one which is
the lowest risk of flooding
and where development is considered
acceptable in principle
and then it does go on to say that this
information has not been updated on the
EA's external maps at the time of
writing this report but has been
confirmed to the LPA LPA by
correspondence which is available on the
application file
however I can't see
that information on the file to confirm
that but obviously as it's in the
reports and that would be the the status
of the application when it was
considered by committee members before
so my follow-up to that is how much
weight can we give that
given the EA maps have not been updated
have we sought an updated map from the
given the work that was done on the
culvert
foreign
I can't answer the question in terms of
whether we have sought that information
but it would be
um based on the information that we've
obviously got on this site on our
systems it's still showing as being
entirely within flood zone 3 which has
got the highest probability of flooding
so which is why obviously members
considered the application before and we
asked for the information in terms of
assessing that flood risk and assessing
whether any mitigation measures would be
required to assist in flood risk um but
making the flood risks accepted on that
site
we don't have anything in the
confirmation from the applicants
relating to the EA so there's no
confirmation
via the applicants from the EA so whilst
it is noted in the letter that was
received early this week
on behalf of the applicants we don't
have any confirmation from the EA
have the EA been consulted on the letter
you received earlier in the week
we haven't carried out any consultation
with the EA on on their resubmitted
information no understood thank you
councilor Jennings oh hang on a second
captain yes Emily
um in respect to Consulting the
environment agency on an application of
this scale it's very likely that if we
did consult them they would come back
and say to refer to the standing advice
because of applications of this scale
there's standing advice on the
government's website in respect of
dealing with
applications like this a sort of
householder of this size
councilor Jennings please
the independent Consultants report on
the flooding is that admissible as
evidence
the yes so the earlier this week we did
receive
um a letter from the planning
Consultants acting on behalf of the
applicant
um mentioning that the flood risk
assessment had well had been the flood
risk had been reduced because of the
cohorting on the site but we haven't had
any confirmation either from the EA or
or any other
documents to to demonstrate this
oh cancer Adam please
thank you
um with regards to the flood map that
you consulted which showed it in flood
zone three did that also include the the
Jason Chapel being in within that same
flood zone
on the system that we work from it
clearly shows the application site
entitled within flood zone 3 and it
shows
um a small part of the Methodist Church
site being within flood zone 3 but the
majority is outside of the flood zone so
that the building itself is outside of
the flood zone
any other points of clarification
no oh councilor Harvey
the question is the
the statement of fact was made that I
presume the environment agency has spent
2.7 million pounds on a culvert do you
know anything to contradict that
[Music]
um I am the war member as you know and
yes uh the EA did spend 2.7 million on
the culverting
um
I mean other than me telling you that I
have no specific evidence I do have
photos of me with the EA whilst they're
putting the new pipes in if you'd like
to see me inside a pipe I'll happily
show you it
I think that's going Beyond The Pale
but I I do think it's a
clearly the the issue is that the
assessment of flood risk and it seems to
be that
the officers are relying upon a map
which is hasn't been updated since
2013. understood um that is a point for
debate and we'll get into that in a
second
um I believe there is still a huge
signpost on the corner directly opposite
the application site that details the
work the EA have done clearly we're not
there so we can't see it for ourselves
but uh certainly it has been and I
believe still it is there
um I think we might just go around the
houses now because we have no definitive
evidence that either I or anyone else
can present
did you want to say something Emily
I was just going to come in on the point
that whilst it appears that the Culver
Works have been undertaken without
um confirmation from the environment
agency about the level
um of of
um benefit that that has had in terms of
reducing flood risk within the area it
would be very difficult to to
categorically
confirm that it no longer Falls within
flood zone three so we would we would
expect that from the environment agency
to be able to give it that definitive
Council Mills thank you um all about the
flood when was the last time they had a
major flood there that caused the
problem with the housing do we know
do we know
okay it's all right then
we don't have that information I'm
afraid
cancer Curtis are you sure
um I understand that the environment
agency hasn't
confirmed that this now is flood risk
one but have
have we actively sought that
confirmation from the environment agency
uh following the application being heard
by members in December uh the case
officer saw this information via the um
agent for the application numerous times
and and
um in terms of the fledged risk
assessment which would be
um informed by information sort from the
environment agency
but have we as the council or have
offices actually gone directly to the
environment agency to get that
confirmation
I I I can't confirm that the development
management team have but obviously there
are other parties involved in
establishing that information so
within our own service area
we haven't
um but generally on applications like
this where this is a matter of that's
that's contested it's it is usual that
as part of the flood risk assessment
evidence to that effect is submitted by
the applicants
Council Jennings
it was brought up um earlier by
um
the applicant and it was about to if the
extension or the work was less than a
certain side than a flood risk
information was not needed could you
just give me a bit of clarification on
that
because the development is in flood zone
three we would require a level of flood
risk assessment of the application
the information that we would seek would
be proportionate to the size of the
extension and the size of the building
works but we would still require some
assessment of the flood risk and whether
it would exacerbate that flood risk and
whether any mitigation measures would be
required to make the development
acceptable as a minimum
cancer seraphim yeah thank you
um
this extension
okay this extension is built on the
existing single story extension isn't it
yes say part of the the area is no
greater than what's already there
there's a two-story side extension as
well if I just show you the
floor plans again
so if you can see um the floor plan say
the existing ground floor plan is the
plan at the top left of the screen
before I always go enough off the
description of development
over the existing single store extension
and then there's a two-story side
extension to the side of that so where
you can see here the dining room
extension and then above that bedroom
three extension so that would be
projecting into the existing Garden area
so where it's showing the kitchen
projecting into and the bedroom here
um that's where the existing single
story extension is located but there is
a two-story side extension for the
dining room and bedroom to the side of
that so there is an additional footprint
hmm
I was just thinking that uh the actual
rainfall on the on the roof are you
moving into debate here
sorry you can't say seven
um okay are there any more points of
clarification before we go into the
debate and if there aren't I might ask
cancer engine serifin to carry on what
you're saying no cancel any seraphim
would you like to start us off and
debate
no all right I'll let somebody else I'll
pick on someone else then uh who would
like to kick us off
cancer Mills
thanks Mr chairman yeah um interesting
one isn't it um
right I'll just kick off then I actually
haven't got any problems with this I
really haven't
um
it was only at the last minute we um
last time it was
let's go back and look at it again
um the flat race assessment is a bit
debatable at the moment isn't it is it
is it or isn't it a flood risk there's a
lot of work going into
to stop a flood risk so at the moment Mr
chairman I'm uh
oh listen what everybody else says but
I'm I'm a problem with it thank you
thank you I'm supposed to cancel Adam
please
thank you uh I I mean I remember this
application
um from when it came in before I think
we went through in some detail there and
clearly the main bone of contention
tonight is the flooding I think that the
officers have clearly been diligent in
going through the information that
they've got
I'm based on the you know the the
speakers who are who we've heard from
which is why we're all here at committee
to hear from them they've suggested that
you know there's an update of
information which
um supersedes what what's being
considered and I think it's not
unreasonable therefore to consider that
the particularly given um the the points
that because I had so seraphim was
asking about in terms of increasing
impermeable area the risk the flooding
is marginal notwithstanding the the
requirement to investigate that in the
the flood zone that we had
on that basis I'd say that I'm very
happy to to go along with the grant
because again we that's the decision we
looked at before and I think the
marginal impact that would be affecting
flooding flood risk is uh is acceptable
and you know based on what we've heard
reduced the uh the weight that's
attached to that reason to refusal just
one Claire did you propose Grant then uh
yes thank you very much councilor
Kendall please
this is this is debate but I may need to
have clarification as well I want to
find a way of granting this application
like Council Adam I can't see anything
in common sense that would say this is
in any way dangerous in terms of flood
risk in any way harmful to the setting
it is only a benefit we need to find a
way of doing this my cons this is where
I'm going to come back to a little bit
of maybe clarification maybe legal
clarification I'm not sure given that we
it's set we have got
policy evidence in this report here that
says this is flood zone three
does that represent some sort of if we
were to Grant
does that represent some sort of
um I don't know what the right word is
reputational harm to the district
council are we in some way liable if we
do that even though we know that perhaps
this flood flood zone is wrong
I want I want to know more about that
before I can go any further with this
there we go I think
rather than making an assumption
based on what people may have said I
think we need to satisfy ourselves that
it isn't
in zone three
um and I think that's what you were
really wanting to know that's precisely
what I want to know so I want to Grant
this on if every reason that I've stated
so far I can't second you I
what I'm about to say is something I
really don't want to but I'm going to
have to propose we defer this again
until we get the actual answer because
I'm not I cannot just go with they say
this they say that I'm not satisfied
this is correct
I really don't think it is but I want to
know before we go ahead and Grant this
that we're okay to do so so I've got no
reason I've got no other choice but to
say I propose we defer this application
until we get proper information again
thank you cancer Kendall um before
calling any other speakers I am going to
second that I desperately want to Second
councilor Adam we've made a decision on
the principle it was subject to The
Climate checklist and the flood
satisfaction as we've heard the flood's
uh problem came in at the last minute I
think I believe it was on the update
sheet
we're still no clearer in either our
offices nor members who are ultimately
the decision makers are clearer on
whether it is or isn't flood zone 3 or
flood zone one I think we need to go
away and it's an opportunity for both
officers and for the applicant to get
that information and be definitive of it
can I clarify one thing we obviously
granted subject to The Climate checklist
and satisfactory Flood information
by deferring this and getting that Flood
information definitively if you're
satisfied with it and it is flood zone
one et cetera et cetera et cetera
presumably it doesn't need to come back
to us for a decision because we've
already made that into principal
decision and it is subject to that
information coming forward is that a
fair assessment
it all depends on what your your
decision is so ultimately the previous
um recommended well the previous
decision that that Council has made was
was that it was approved or granted
um subject to the two matters which was
the climate change checklist and the
flood risk being resolved
um and you also
um listed you know that that decision
included the relevant conditions in that
case if you if you want to make that
same recommendation
subject to the removal of the climate
change checklist because we're satisfied
that that that's been submitted then
that would
fall to officers to to delegate it once
we were satisfied that that flood risk
information was acceptable
cancer Kendall having made the proposal
are you comfortable with what has just
been said
so I'm clear then so the previous Grand
subject to would go ahead
in line with the
in line with the flood being flood zone
being found to be flood zone one and in
theory then it would be delegated as
ground at that point am I correct I'm
sorry I'm sounding like an idiot just
want to make sure I get this right
you are right to question that so my
understanding of it um just so we're
clear is that it is exactly the same
um proposal that we had on the previous
application so it is Grant Subject to
satisfactory climate checklist now we
can that can go away because we've had
that so now it will be subject to uh
approved flood
uh assessment now that flood assessment
as I understand it would be a
confirmation from the EA that it is in
whichever flood zone it's in
and if it's determined to be one minimal
therefore move to Grant if it's three
the applicant still required to provide
the appropriate assessment to show that
there would no be there would be no
worsening of any flood uh effect there
okay I'm happy with an outlet you've
explained that I now understand that
it's getting late at night
do you want me to withdraw my proposal I
I'd like you to remake it along the
lines of what was just saying
hang on hang on shall I do it no because
I'm conscious of the fact we've had a
proposition to defer we've had a
proposition ground there we need to keep
it tidy don't we so I I you know what
I'm saying here well I mean okay I'm
gonna remove my seconding of yours and I
will and therefore you can choose what
you want to do and I will refer I'll
remove my proposal as well you something
you're happy to go for marvelous bear
with me now
this is this is getting awfully
complicated over something that I've
considered to be quite straightforward
so
I'm going to propose that we grunt
subject to receipt of further flooding
details those flooding details obviously
being confirmation from the
environmental agency and if it's flood
zone three then confirmation from the
applicant of the impact it's going to
have
Council Adam would you second me I'll be
very happy to Second that's very kindly
thank you ever so much counselor
Jennings do you want to say something I
don't know about is there such a thing
as a flood risk too
if there is then we also need to
incorporate that
I I think the officers have got the
message that
we just all we need to do is tidy up the
flood thing we need to have a definitive
of what the impact it actually is so
what zone it's in and if it's in a Zone
deemed to require any further assessment
from the applicant the applicant is
obliged to provide that
we're in no worse the situation than we
were before we're just going to get more
information so
if the conditions are as they would have
been previously which are commencement
in three years in line with plans
materials
um
and actually that's it the climate
checklist is already done and then
obviously we've got the flood stuff so
is everyone happy everyone understand
what we're doing now I'm glad you do are
you satisfied that we have got to where
we've got to yes and obviously as we're
making as we're making a new
recommendation I will presume that the
the reason for overturning the officer's
decision Remains the Same as those
reasons that were considered last time
correct okay let's have a
condition another condition that I
didn't say was compliance with the
climate checklist which is a standard
condition
um
I think we're happy we can move forward
but let's have a vote The Proposal is to
grant for the reasons uh previously set
out subject to the flood risk assessment
can I'm sure of hands please in favor
please
that is unanimous to committee therefore
resolves to Grant application
2201005 fuel Corner Cottage subject to
um do we have any urgent business
no in that case members members of the
public thank you very much indeed for
your efforts today we will see you next
week meetings closed
yeah I'm just going to read the whole